I'll sign off by showing
you some pair of pandas.
We are about to plot two columns
simultaneously on one graph.
That is close and
adjusted close for the Apple stock.
Don't worry about how to extract
multiple columns from the data frame.
But intuitively you use
a double square brackets and
pass the two column names,
that is Close and Adj Close.
We go ahead and plot this.
Here's the graph.
You can observe two lines.
One is blue, which corresponds
to Close; and one is green,
which corresponds to Adj Close.
Observe that we did not write
code to print the legend, or
give color to each of the graph lines.
This is the pair of the Python pandas.
The blue line corresponds
to the close value, and
the green line corresponds to
the adjusted close values.
You will learn in the further
lesson why there is a difference.
That's all for now,
I'll see you in the next lesson.
Happy coding.